Good morning, oh my god. Good morning. Oh my god, you're eating the cookies. I put them out. Oh my god, there's just crumbs here and all the milk is gone. Or is that Sean? Sean, did you drink the milk? I might have done both.
早上好，天哪。早上好。天哪，你在吃饼干。我把它们拿出来了。天哪，这里只剩下碎屑了，牛奶也没了。那是肖恩吗？肖恩，你喝了牛奶吗？我可能两样都干了。
I might have eaten the cookies and drank the milk. Hey Sean, where are your pants? Uh oh. It's a holiday surprise. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart.
我可能把饼干吃了，牛奶也喝了。嘿，肖恩，你的裤子呢？噢，不。这是节日惊喜。欢迎来到《Smartless》。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. So what do we got going on for the holidays, you guys? We're going to be... I'm looking to... So what do we got going on for the holidays, you guys? We're going to be? I'm looking to, I'm going to be going to a beach environment and you're going to be there as well, Will.
Less。Smart。Less。那么，伙计们，我们假期有什么安排？我们要……我正在看……那么，伙计们，我们假期有什么安排？我们要去？我正在看，我要去海边环境，你也会在那里，威尔。
And I think it's bullshit that Sean's not going to be there. Well, what are we going to do pre-Christmas? We should get together. I'm sure we'll be at a holiday party. Maybe I got the invite for Conan. Are you coming? I think so, yes. But you said that you might not be able to make it.
我觉得肖恩不去太扯了。好吧，圣诞节前我们要做什么？我们应该聚一聚。我相信我们会参加一个节日派对。也许我收到了柯南的邀请。你要来吗？我想是的，没错。但你说过你可能去不了。
Because there's another thing on that night that we gotta go to, but that's not starting until nine. So it looks like I can squeeze Conan in. Wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute. Oh no. Wait a minute, wait a minute. No, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute. Oh, excuse me, excuse me.
因为那天晚上还有别的事要参加，但那要到九点才开始。所以看起来我可以挤出时间去柯南那里。等一下，等一下，等一下。噢，不。等一下，等一下。不，等一下，等一下，等一下。噢，抱歉，抱歉。
I just get, I guess you just ambush me, Arnett. Bateman, Bateman, you're gonna squeeze me in? Yeah, I'm gonna see, I'm gonna be one of those guys. You're gonna squeeze me in. You're gonna be the early part of my night, the night that I don't really care about because then I'm gonna go to the party that I really wanna go to after this.
我只是，我想你只是伏击我，阿内特。贝特曼，贝特曼，你要挤出时间给我？是的，我要看看，我要成为那种人。你要挤出时间给我。你要成为我那天晚上早些时候的安排，那个我不太在意的晚上，因为之后我要去我真正想去的派对。
Oh, and I know, and guess what? Let me tell you why. Guess what? I know what that party is, by the way. I know what that party is, and if I could get into that party, I'd be at that party instead of my party. Yeah, no, she doesn't like you. Hey, can I tell you something? You're not going. First of all, that is Christiane Amampour loves me and she will have me to her party.
噢，我知道，你猜怎么着？让我告诉你为什么。猜怎么着？顺便说一句，我知道那个派对是什么。我知道那个派对是什么，如果我能进那个派对，我会去那个派对，而不是我的派对。是的，不，她不喜欢你。嘿，我能告诉你一件事吗？你不会去的。首先，克里斯蒂安·阿曼普尔爱我，她会邀请我去她的派对。
That is the party everyone wants to go to. Let me say something Jason and that's called speed. You'll pick it up someday. Let me say something, Bateman. You bitched, you bitched, you bitched on this podcast. You bitched, you bitched on this podcast. What's it? Live on stage, Conan, remember? And on stage. And on stage.
那是每个人都想去的派对。让我说点什么，杰森，那叫速度。你总有一天会学会的。让我说点什么，贝特曼。你在播客上抱怨，抱怨，抱怨。你在播客上抱怨，抱怨。是什么？现场直播，柯南，记得吗？在舞台上。在舞台上。
You bitched and moaned on Harmless. What's the name of it? What is it? It's Harmless. Harmless. You bitched, you bitched. Harmless. You bitched and moaned about not being invited to Conan's Christmas party, which has become
你在《Harmless》上抱怨和呻吟。名字叫什么？是什么？是《Harmless》。《Harmless》。你抱怨，你抱怨。《Harmless》。你抱怨和呻吟没有被邀请参加柯南的圣诞派对，这已经成为了
an iconic party. It's quite a thing. Everyone goes... And yet I didn't... And so last year was the first invite, finally. I invited you and what did you do? I couldn't make it. And what were you doing instead?
一个标志性的派对。这真是个了不起的事情。每个人都去……然而我没有……所以去年是第一次邀请，终于。我邀请了你，你做了什么？我没能去。那你当时在做什么？
I can't remember. Yesterday. I remember. I remember what you were doing instead. You were't make it. What were you doing instead? I can't remember, yesterday. I remember. What was I doing? I remember what you were doing instead. You were seeing that. You were at Jen's. No, you were, no! He wasn't at Jen's, in a sense.
我不记得了。昨天。我记得。我记得你当时在做什么。你没能去。你当时在做什么？我不记得了，昨天。我记得。我在做什么？我记得你当时在做什么。你在珍那里。不，你在，不！他不在珍那里，某种意义上。
I'm gonna go back in my calendar here. December 20, December 20, 23. No, you weren't in town. No. Was it the 23rd? Guess what? A friend of mine saw you. I was at Jen's party.
我要翻翻我的日历。12月20日，12月20日，23日。不，你不在城里。不。是23号吗？猜怎么着？我的一个朋友看见你了。我在珍的派对上。
Nope, you showed up late at Jen's party. A friend of mine saw you at Minakike Mufflers on Los Ciencos. They said that you- That's when the lines are the shortest. They said you were there for four hours, and listen to this, hanging around, hanging around with no need of a muffler repair. Just chatting people up.
不，你迟到了珍的派对。我的一个朋友在洛斯辛科斯的米纳基克消声器店看见你了。他们说你——那是排队最短的时候。他们说你在那里待了四个小时，听着，闲逛，闲逛，根本不需要修理消声器。只是在和人聊天。
I have an electric car, yeah, there's no muffler at all. Conan, the worst part is that I heard that he ripped... He was going to go to your party. He ripped his own muffler off. Yes. Just to delay going to your house. He ripped it off just so he wouldn't have to go. Now look, everyone says,
我有一辆电动车，是的，根本没有消声器。柯南，最糟糕的是我听说他撕掉了……他本来要去你的派对。他撕掉了自己的消声器。是的。只是为了推迟去你家。他把它撕掉只是为了不用去。现在看，每个人都说，
Oh, would you go to Conan's party? Would you go to Jen Aniston's party? Of course everyone would go to Jen Aniston's party. She's beautiful. She's iconic. She's a movie star. she's a TV star. And what am I, some thin-lipped, beady-eyed creep? I get it, no one comes to my party. But.
噢，你会去柯南的派对吗？你会去珍妮弗·安妮斯顿的派对吗？当然每个人都会去珍妮弗·安妮斯顿的派对。她很漂亮。她是偶像。她是电影明星。她是电视明星。那我算什么，一个薄嘴唇、豆豆眼的怪胎？我明白了，没人来我的派对。但是。
Yeah, those were Sean's words once. He said that everyone set up. I never said that. He wrote them in The New Yorker. They were in a piece from The New Yorker called Why No One Likes Conan O'Brien. Sean, Sean, you've been to this party? I've been to this party, but the only reason I get to go
是的，那是肖恩曾经说过的话。他说每个人都……我从来没说过。他把它们写在《纽约客》里了。它们出现在《纽约客》一篇名为《为什么没人喜欢柯南·奥布莱恩》的文章里。肖恩，肖恩，你去过这个派对吗？我去过这个派对，但我能去的唯一原因
is because I have to go early to set up. It's, oh. Yeah. You have to work it. You have to remember, Sean, before he hit it, on Will and Grace, worked the party for seven years. He was a cater-waiter. Yeah, he was a cater-waiter.
是因为我必须早点去布置。噢。是的。你得干活。你得记住，肖恩，在他成名之前，在《威尔和格蕾丝》里，他为那个派对工作了七年。他是个餐饮服务员。是的，他是个餐饮服务员。
I feel like that's a true story. But that is a true story. I set up some party stuff at Anthony Edwards' house before. Really? Was he kind to you? He was very kind, he was very kind. Good guy. But Conan's party, your party's always super fun.
我觉得那是个真实的故事。但那确实是个真实的故事。我以前在安东尼·爱德华兹家布置过派对。真的吗？他对你友善吗？他非常友善，他非常友善。好人。但柯南的派对，你的派对总是超级有趣。
Wait, Conan, don't start going like, good guy. What are you, the decider of like, this guy? Good guy. You don't know. You can't judge people. Can I say something? I'll tell you who a good guy is. A good guy is someone who, I think I've done Smart List a couple times,
等等，柯南，别开始说，好人。你是什么，这种人的裁决者吗？好人。你不知道。你不能评判别人。我能说点什么吗？我告诉你谁是好人。好人是那种，我想我上过几次《Smartless》，
sort of the boost the numbers for you guys a little bit, and helped you get launched, I think, which was a big help. People were like, I don't want to hear these guys, who are these gotta work actors? And then, hey, Conan's going on, I'll check it out. But listen, then, so I did that for you guys, okay? Then, to return the favor, Sean Hayes,
算是帮你们提高了一点收听率，并帮助你们起步，我想，这很有帮助。人们当时说，我不想听这些家伙，这些是什么必须工作的演员？然后，嘿，柯南要上节目了，我去看看。但听着，然后，我为你们做了这些，好吗？然后，为了回报，肖恩·海耶斯，
Ben here, talk to me on my podcast. Will Arnett comes sometimes when we don't even invite him, just hanging around, holding onto his muffler, and then- How have I not been invited? Oh, you have been invited to my podcast many times. No way. Many times. No way.
本在这里，在我的播客上跟我谈谈。威尔·阿内特有时甚至在我们没邀请他时也会来，只是闲逛，拿着他的消声器，然后——我怎么没被邀请？噢，你被多次邀请参加我的播客了。不可能。多次。不可能。
Many times. Adam, many times. Many times. And your publicist, this is a quote from your publicist, not his cup of tea. Not his cup of tea. Bullshit! That's fucking bullshit.
多次。亚当，多次。多次。还有你的公关，这是你公关的一句原话，不是他的菜。不是他的菜。扯淡！那真是他妈的扯淡。
I swear on my kid's life, I can't remember being invited onto your show. Ask Adam if this is true. Conan, ask Adam if this is true. Adam, how many? Three times he said he couldn't make it because of prior muffler engagements. Okay, alright. Listen, that's a three-time callback and that's a felony. Listen, Adam, Adam, Adam, is it not true
我以我孩子的生命发誓，我不记得被邀请上你的节目。问亚当这是不是真的。柯南，问亚当这是不是真的。亚当，多少次？他说他三次因为之前的消声器预约而没能去。好吧，好吧。听着，那是三次拒绝，那是重罪。听着，亚当，亚当，亚当，难道不是真的
that he has been invited many times and that his publicist, I don't remember her name, I think it's Enid Crud, I think is her name, said not his cup of tea. No, I'm not with her. I can confirm he's been invited multiple times. You left Crud? Wow.
他被邀请了很多次，而且他的公关，我不记得她的名字了，我想是伊妮德·克鲁德，我想是这个名字，说不是他的菜。不，我没和她在一起。我可以确认他被多次邀请了。你离开克鲁德了？哇。
No, I'm texting Kara Trepichio and Christine Trepichio right now saying show me the receipts of my invites to Conan. That's right, because there's always a money exchange when I ask you to come up. Oh, have I ever been? Do you think that they're gonna let you feel bad about this? This is their businesses,
不，我正在给卡拉·特雷皮奇奥和克里斯汀·特雷皮奇奥发短信，说给我看我被邀请参加柯南节目的证据。没错，因为当我请你来的时候总是有金钱往来。噢，我曾经去过吗？你觉得他们会让你为此感到难过吗？这是他们的生意，
just dancing around your rage fits, babe, and there's no way that they're gonna feed into this. And now tell you something. Conan, how do you. Yeah, and now say something, say something. Conan, how do you spell your name real quick? Okay, all right. Jason, if that's even your real name. I-N or A-N. Jason, it's K-O-N-I-N.
只是绕着你的愤怒发作跳舞，宝贝，他们绝不会助长这种情绪。现在告诉你一件事。柯南，你怎么。是的，现在说点什么，说点什么。柯南，你名字怎么拼，快点。好吧，好吧。杰森，如果那真是你的真名的话。I-N还是A-N。杰森，是K-O-N-I-N。
Jesus. Did you hear the little whoop that text just went off? In real time, we're gonna get a response here. But wait, but now, but Jason, you're gonna go this year for the very first time. This is gonna be super fun. To the party, but not to the podcast. I would like to be a guest on Kona's podcast.
天哪。你听到那个短信发出的轻微声音了吗？实时地，我们马上会得到回复。但等等，但现在，但杰森，你今年第一次要去。这会超级有趣。去派对，但不是去播客。我想成为柯南播客的嘉宾。
You have been invited! Kona has a podcast empire. You have been invited. He's our North Star, what he's been able to build there with that podcast empire. And I would like to go see how it's really done. Well, thank you. And you know what?
你已经被邀请了！柯南有一个播客帝国。你已经被邀请了。他是我们的北极星，他能在那里建立那个播客帝国。我想去看看它是怎么真正做到的。好吧，谢谢。你知道吗？
Right off camera, he was going like this. And just so in case anyone knows, that's either the jerk off motion or the shucking porn motion. I don't know what that is Wait, you know, I'm gonna wrap this up soon because I have a guest when is Taylor Swift coming in She's coming in now. She's coming in. Oh my god. I don't know what the cat you guys probably had her but Anyway, she's coming in which she's coming in with no Travis Kelsey. I'm the white whale Anyway, why are you wearing? Why are you wearing such a thick leather jacket indoors? Yeah, leather jacket indoors, yeah.
在镜头外，他一直在做这个动作。以防有人知道，那要么是手淫的动作，要么是剥色情片的动作。我不知道那是什么。等等，你知道，我很快就要结束了，因为我有嘉宾。泰勒·斯威夫特什么时候来？她现在就来。她现在就来。天哪。我不知道你们可能已经有她了，但无论如何，她要来了，她来的时候没有特拉维斯·凯尔西。我是那条白鲸。无论如何，你为什么穿着？你为什么在室内穿这么厚的皮夹克？是的，室内穿皮夹克，是的。
I was given this leather jacket by the actors who portrayed both Starsky and Hutch about 15 years ago. And I swore they said, we'll give this to you if you wear it on the podcast every day, and I do. I do, and it's very cold here in our studio because we also store, we use to have meat storage facility primarily. Look at that, you do have a beautiful studio there. We're hostage videos here with little laptops.
这件皮夹克是大约15年前扮演《警界双雄》的演员给我的。我发誓他们说，如果你每天在播客上穿它，我们就把它给你，我确实穿了。我确实穿了，而且我们的工作室很冷，因为我们以前主要用作肉类储存设施。看，你们那里确实有一个漂亮的工作室。我们这里是带小笔记本电脑的人质视频。
I find to really get a great interview, I haven't really listened to what you guys are doing, but to get a really good interview, you want to be in person and have a real connection. By the way, let us know if, when you do get a good interview, let us know if your theory bears out. Oh!
我发现要真正获得一次很棒的采访，我还没真正听过你们在做什么，但要获得一次非常好的采访，你需要亲自到场并建立真正的联系。顺便说一句，如果你确实获得了好的采访，让我们知道你的理论是否成立。噢！
We'd love to hear. Nap! We'd love to hear. Now Conan, if I were ever to be invited to be on your podcast, would I have to drive to you and be in some studio and be camera ready and hair and makeup and all that? That's not a chance.
我们很想听听。Nap！我们很想听听。现在柯南，如果我曾经被邀请参加你的播客，我必须开车去找你，在某个工作室里，还要准备好摄像、发型和化妆等等吗？那是不可能的。
I'll make a deal with you. Okay, Jason, I'm gonna deal with you. I don't ever want you to leave your bubble. I want you to stay in the world where you're it and everything's cool. So I would probably... Wait, here's a real time response from my publicist. I said, have I ever been invited to be on Conan's podcast?
我和你做个交易。好吧，杰森，我要和你做个交易。我永远不想让你离开你的泡沫。我希望你留在那个你是主角、一切都很酷的世界里。所以我可能会……等等，这是我公关的实时回复。我说，我曾经被邀请参加柯南的播客吗？
And? She says, yes. Yes! And you asked us to tell them you were focused on your own for now. Wow! Exclamation point. Yeah, and how many years have you guys been focusing on your own?
然后呢？她说，是的。是的！而且你让我们告诉他们你目前专注于自己的节目。哇！感叹号。是的，你们专注于自己的节目多少年了？
Holy shit. This isn't a new endeavor for you guys. I'm so embarrassed. When was that? Yeah, yeah. I don't remember that at all. Oh, right, no. And I make it a point to do people's podcasts
该死。这对你们来说不是什么新尝试。我太尴尬了。那是什么时候？是的，是的。我一点都不记得了。噢，对了，不。我特意去参加别人的播客
that have been so nice with us. Done Dax's multiple times. Oh, multiple times for Dax, oh that's nice. David Cross's one that I don't even know if it's on the air anymore. Listen, that has never actually gone out. David Cross's is just. What's the address?
那些对我们很好的人。参加过达克斯的多次。噢，达克斯的多次，噢，那很好。大卫·克罗斯的那个，我甚至不知道它还在不在播。听着，那个从来没真正播出过。大卫·克罗斯的只是。地址是什么？
I'm driving over there right now. No, no, no, I don't want you here anymore. I'm driving, tell Taylor to pump it. And she's now the second guest. Can I tell you something else? This is gonna be an awkward Christmas. I don't buy this whole thing, and I don't think your compatriots on the podcast do either.
我现在就开车过去。不，不，不，我不想让你再来了。我正在开车，告诉泰勒加油。她现在是第二个嘉宾。我能再告诉你一件事吗？这将是一个尴尬的圣诞节。我不相信这一切，我也不认为你在播客上的同伴相信。
This whole thing that, oh, someone who works for me was cruel and mean on my behalf. That's coming from you, Bateman. No, exactly. That's coming from you. Yes, you asked us to tell them you were focused on your offering. I'm admitting to there was some garbage
这一切，噢，为我工作的人代表我残忍和刻薄。那是你说的，贝特曼。不，完全正确。那是你说的。是的，你让我们告诉他们你专注于自己的节目。我承认有一些垃圾
that came out of my mouth that I don't remember, but I'm not denying. And I owe you a hugey, and I'm going to come over and give it to you. Right now, that's your entrance. No, no, no, I don't want you there now. I think that's the truth. No, I'm coming, I'm coming.
从我嘴里说出来，我不记得了，但我没有否认。我欠你一个大恩情，我要过去把它给你。现在，那是你的出场。不，不，不，我现在不想让你去。我觉得那是事实。不，我要去，我要去。
Because what am I going to do? I'm your new sidekick. I'm going to stand around and twist. I'm your new Andy Richter. I can't wait. I'm your podcast Andy Richter for at least 12 episodes. I'm gonna sit around at my party and watch You Not Eat and then look at your watch while you think about,
因为我要做什么？我是你的新搭档。我要站在旁边扭动。我是你的新安迪·里希特。我等不及了。我是你至少12集的播客安迪·里希特。我要坐在我的派对上看着你不吃东西，然后看着你的手表，当你思考，
oh, when am I gonna go see Jen's? I gotta go to Jen's. I gotta go to Jen's. I wanna be there when she's getting a, you know, a dry blow haircut, whatever it's called. I wanna be there when she's styled. No, I'm not, I'm not. It's a blowout at a dry bar.
噢，我什么时候去珍那里？我得去珍那里。我得去珍那里。我想在她做干洗吹发时在那里，不管那叫什么。我想在她做造型时在那里。不，我不是，我不是。那是干洗店的吹发。
Okay, well I'm sorry. I didn't grow up in Hollywood like you freaks. I come from the real working class. I'm from Toronto, you asshole. Oh yeah, Toronto, North La Cienega. That isn't even funny. I'm giving you stuff that's C plus material at best. Would you ever, hey Conan,
好吧，我很抱歉。我没有像你们这些怪胎一样在好莱坞长大。我来自真正的工人阶级。我是多伦多人，你这个混蛋。噢，是的，多伦多，北拉谢内加。那一点都不好笑。我给你的东西充其量是C+水平。你会吗，嘿柯南，
would you ever get a blowout on your hair? Let's just say it's been done He knows what that means nobody know what I'm gonna be honest with you will I don't understand Okay means okay, and if you want it if you want to drive a truck you want to drive the best truck possible If I will say this about you Conan I'm gonna play a compliment here because it is a professional. I will say this about you Conan, I'm gonna put you in compliment here because it is the holidays. And I will say this, I did your podcast years ago, the first time I did it, I did a live show, I've done a lot, I've helped you out a lot.
你会去吹头发吗？我们只能说它已经做过了。他知道那意味着什么，没人知道。我要对你诚实，威尔，我不明白。好吧，意味着好吧，如果你想开卡车，你想开最好的卡车。如果我能对你评价这一点，柯南，我要在这里奉承一下，因为这是假期。我会说这一点，我几年前做过你的播客，第一次做的时候，我做了现场表演，我做了很多，我帮了你很多。
You've done a lot, you've helped me out a lot. You know what, you repaid the favor that you, the three of you, two of you have repaid it, very kindly, thank you. Yeah, and I will say it was after doing your podcast, I was able to come back and I said to these guys, I said, if this frickin' ding-dong, or no, if Conan can... What are we doing?
你做了很多，你帮了我很多。你知道吗，你回报了你，你们三个，你们两个已经回报了，非常友善，谢谢。是的，我会说是在做完你的播客之后，我能够回来，我对这些家伙说，我说，如果这个该死的笨蛋，或者不，如果柯南能……我们在做什么？
What are we doing? You know what I mean? What's the fella's name over there? Adam? What's his name? Adam, Adam says. Adam, okay, Adam. I know Adam here.
我们在做什么？你知道我的意思吗？那边那个家伙叫什么名字？亚当？他叫什么名字？亚当，亚当说。亚当，好吧，亚当。我认识这里的亚当。
Adam's great. Hi, Adam. Hi, Adam. Let's just make sure you got a good Wi-Fi signal there on your phone or bars or something like that Let's just keep an eye on it. We got an incoming We're gonna book it right now I'm gonna guess toast when you need to go out of town and vacation with your beautiful family going you need someone to go in there
亚当很棒。嗨，亚当。嗨，亚当。让我们确保你的手机上有很好的Wi-Fi信号或信号格之类的东西。让我们留意一下。我们有进来的。我们现在就预订。当你需要出城和美丽的家人度假时，我猜会祝酒，你需要有人去那里
I'm going to the beach you guys are going to. Aren't you going to a beach together? I want to go to that beach. I want to hang with, we'll do it from the beach. I want to do it with the, I just want to hang with the smart was crowd. That's the cool crowd on the block. No one wants to hang with you. Oh, it came, they're here, she's got follow up here.
我要去你们要去的海滩。你们不是要一起去海滩吗？我想去那个海滩。我想和，我们会在海滩上做。我想和，我只是想和《Smartless》的人群在一起。那是街区里最酷的人群。没人想和你在一起。噢，来了，他们在这里，她有后续。
The request came in when you were filming Black Rabbit and then they followed up to ask. Okay, so this is in process. So this is in process. What's Black Rabbit? This is the live project. Black Rabbit's a new show, it's gonna be on Netflix next year.
请求是在你拍摄《黑兔》时进来的，然后他们跟进询问。好吧，所以这正在进行中。所以这正在进行中。《黑兔》是什么？这是现场项目。《黑兔》是一部新剧，明年会在Netflix上播出。
His new show is gonna be on Netflix. He's amazing in it. Oh, I'm gonna come on and promote it on your show. Sorry. Oh, so you'll come when it's time to promote something. Okay. Well, I hope you get the word out on Black Rabbit. Call Adam immediately.
他的新剧明年会在Netflix上播出。他在里面很棒。噢，我要去你的节目上宣传它。抱歉。噢，所以你会在需要宣传什么的时候来。好吧。好吧，我希望你能宣传《黑兔》。立即给亚当打电话。
Listen, listen, guys, let's end on a happy note, which is it's the holidays. And hey, you're the best looking guys I know. I love you guys, you're hilarious. Love you too, Colin, it's the broom. Two of you have meant a lot to me. And I just wanna say I look forward to seeing you at my party.
听着，听着，伙计们，让我们以快乐的基调结束，那就是假期到了。嘿，你们是我认识的最帅的家伙。我爱你们，你们太搞笑了。我也爱你，柯南，是扫帚。你们两个对我意义重大。我只想说我期待在我的派对上见到你们。
And then we'll all leave after three minutes and go to Jen's Thank you Conan for the holiday cheer we love you I love you, and I'm sorry and the payback is gonna be you're gonna you're gonna feel horrible how much I give You're gonna feel horrible how much I give in the days to come. In the days to come, he's doing your podcast this Saturday, he's gonna give a speech standing next to the ham. I'm gonna break 16 hams. Guys, I gotta go. T-Swift is here. Peace out. Peace out. Thank you, Conan. You're the best.
然后我们三分钟后都会离开去珍那里。谢谢柯南带来的节日快乐，我们爱你。我爱你，我很抱歉，回报将是你会，你会感到可怕，我给了多少。你会感到可怕，我在未来的日子里给了多少。在未来的日子里，他这个星期六要上你的播客，他要在火腿旁边发表演讲。我要弄碎16个火腿。伙计们，我得走了。T-Swift在这里。再见。再见。谢谢，柯南。你是最棒的。
Bye, Conan. Bye-bye, you guys. God damn it. Peace out. Peace out. Thank you, Conan. You're the best. Bye, Conan. Bye-bye, you guys. God damn it. Smart. Blast. Smart.
再见，柯南。再见，伙计们。该死。再见。再见。谢谢，柯南。你是最棒的。再见，柯南。再见，伙计们。该死。Smart。Blast。Smart。
Blast. Smart. Blast. Smart. Blast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Blast。Smart。Blast。Smart。Blast。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。